[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
ein Winterabend in der Berliner
Residenzstraße hier kommt es zu einer
skurrilen Szene wie in einer billigen
Gangster Komödie tapsen 13 Schurken in
ein Wettbüro die meisten von ihnen haben
die Kapuzen ihrer Hoodies aufgezogen und
blicken finster 3 rein Augenblicke
später drehen alle wieder um und stürmen
raus in den wenigen Momenten dazwischen
ist der Mord passiert über den wir heute
sprechen hier ist eine neue Folge
unseres Podcasts Tatort Deutschland
schön dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid ich
bin Tony und ich bin Mirko hallo
der zehnte januar 2014 ist ein
langweiliger Wintertag wie es ihnen in
Berlin häufig gibt morgens um sechs hat
es ein bisschen geregnet nachmittags
lässt sich die Sonne blicken abends
ziehen Wolken durch mit sechs bis sieben
Grad ist es recht mild und so schön der
Name klingt die Residenzstraße ist eine
schmucklose vierspurige Hauptstraße im
grauen Bezirk reinigendorf an der Ecke
zur Hausotter Straße steht ein
Mehrfamilienhaus mit Geschäften dahin
unter anderem ein billig Bäcker eine
Dönerbude und das Wettbüro mit der
Aufschrift
expect.com
22:55 Uhr die 13 Männer betreten das
Wettbüro eine Überwachungskamera filmt
die Szene allerdings ohne Ton
ein Polizeisprecher beschreibt die
Aufnahme später auf einer
Pressekonferenz so
schnell kommentiert das ist das ein
Betreten der der Rocker Angehörigen in
das Lokal sind
hinten wieder raus
in der Zwischenzeit gibt es einen
Zwischenraum
so das ist der Zwischenraum da gibt das
ist wie so schlauchartiges Gebäude
danach hierdurch geht es in dem in dem
Raum in dem das Opfer sitzt
da gibt es zurückdrängen die die
sonstigen also nicht Besucher weg und
Rauschen wieder raus
und das ist das Geschehen vor Ort in dem
Film sieht man den Mann der am
empfangstresendienst hat sowie einen
rauchenden Kunden daneben beide scheinen
zu ahnen dass etwas Gefährliches
passiert aber auch dass diese Gefahr
nicht sie betrifft sie gucken den
finsteren Typen etwas ratlos hinterher
wer genau zählt der kann sehen dass 13
Männer reingehen aber nur zwölf wieder
herauskommen der letzte Mann hat das
expect Wettbüro durch die Hintertür
verlassen
gerade mal 25 Sekunden hat der Überfall
in Reinickendorf gedauert danach liegt
ein Mann tot im Hinterraum des Wettbüros
der 26 Jahre alte Tasche Ölberg acht Mal
wurde in seine Richtung gefeuert sechs
Kugeln trafen das Opfer Respekt wusste
dass ihn die Hells Angels im wie sie
hatten und trug deshalb oft eine
schusssichere Weste aber in den
scheinbar sicheren Räumen des Wettbüros
hat er sie abgelegt
es wird zwar noch Jahre dauern bis diese
Hinrichtung juristisch aufgearbeitet ist
aber
Szenekenner Wissen vom ersten Moment an
hier geht es um Konflikte im
Rockermilieu
daher ist weg wird den Bandidos
zugerechnet er soll ein Vierteljahr vor
den Schüssen in Reinickendorf an einer
Schlägerei in Mitte beteiligt gewesen
sein vor der Disco Traffic am
Alexanderplatz war ein Streit eskaliert
und dabei wurde ein Mitglied der Hells
Angels mit einem Messer verletzt
zugestochen hat Respekt
gönnen wir uns mal an dieser Stelle ein
bisschen Hintergrund zu den Hells Angels
Mirko schon der Ursprung der Truppe ist
kriegerisch der Name stammt von einer
us-kampfliegerstaffel die im Zweiten
Weltkrieg Deutschland bombardierte am 17
märz 1948 schließen sich Veteranen
dieser Truppe an verschiedenen Orten
Kaliforniens zu Motorradclubs zusammen
ihnen ist der bürgerliche Alltag zu
langweilig sie wollen Partys feiern und
Harley Davidson fahren ihr erster Boss
ist ein Maschinenführer namens Ralph
Sony borgger mit den Jahren kommt zum
Motorradfahren und dem Partys das
organisierte Verbrechen dazu Hells
Angels verdienen er Geld mit Erpressung
zu hälterei und Drogen dazu kommt
Schießereien Waffenbesitz und
Vergewaltigung und noch brisanter wird
die Bedrohungslage durch rockerkriege
denn 1966 gründet sich in Texas eine
tödliche Konkurrenz die Bandidos
die Kriminellen Rockerbanden breiten
sich weltweit aus das erste deutsche
Hells Angels Charter wird 1973 in
Hamburg gegründet weitere Ableger folgen
allerdings bilden sich in Deutschland
viele regionale Clubs die weniger gut
vernetzt sind und keine internationalen
Kontakte haben wie die Hells Angels in
den USA oder deren große Rivalen die
Bandidos nachdem es in den 1990er Jahren
in Skandinavien zu brutalen
Auseinandersetzungen mit mehreren Toten
kommt da eskaliert ab Mitte der 2000er
Jahre der Rockerkrieg zwischen Hells
Angels und Bandidos auch in Deutschland
es kommt zuschlägereien Anschlägen und
Morden was mit dem Mord im Wettbüro 2014
in Berlin passiert ist der vorläufige
Höhepunkt eines rockerkrieges mitten in
der Hauptstadt es ist eine Geschichte
von Konkurrenz Streit Verrat und Rache
im Mittelpunkt damals kann dir padir ein
hünenhafter muskulöser 120 Kilo Mann er
wächst als Sohn eines osramarbeiters aus
der Türkei im Stadtteil gesund Boden auf
sucht früh Anschluss an Gangs an die
Unterwelt trinkt keinen Alkohol geht
lieber Boxen um das Jahr 2014 herum wird
padir-mitglied bei den Bandidos der
Nummer zwei hinter den Hells Angels die
Bandidos gelten als knallhart und locken
reihenweise Zuhälter Hooligans und
Türsteher an sie konkurrieren mit den
Hells Angels um Anabolika Handel um
Bordelle und um die Türen lukrativer
Clubs denn als Einlasser kannst Du
bestimmen wer im Laden Geschäfte macht
aber während die Angels lange ein
deutscher Club bleiben sind die Bandidos
offen für Migranten in Teilen von
Wedding Neukölln oder Weißensee gibt es
deshalb Schnittmengen zwischen Rockern
und Clans
2010 sorgt padir für ein Erdbeben in der
Berliner Rockerszene er läuft mit einer
ganzen Schar von Getreuen zu den Hells
Angels über am Bandidos Clubhaus in
Reinickendorf wird das gelbe Logo mit
dem Mexikaner darauf gegen den Totenkopf
der Angels ausgetauscht zwei Jahre lang
nutzen die Hells Angels ihre neue
Dominanz übernehmen lokale und
straßenreviere der Konkurrenz dann lässt
der Berliner Senat sie verbieten aber
die Rocker sind aus Kreisen von Polizei
und Justiz vorgewandt worden und
schaffen so noch schnell clubvermögen
beiseite und das Verbot hilft auch nicht
gegen den Einfluss der Gangster in den
Problemen im Gegenteil ein paar Jahre
lang gelten Rocker unter jungen Leuten
als cool in einem Musik Video von Fler
stehen die Verbrecher breitbeinig auf
der Straße rum und versuchen gefährlich
auszusehen
Abschiedskuss ja stimmt ich bin ein Alki
ein Nichtsnutz der deiner Freundin
morgens Whisky ins Gesicht Herr auch
Bushido will für sein Gangster Image
gerne ein bisschen cooles der Rocker
abhaben in seinem Musikvideo zum Lied
mitten in der Nacht tritt Katja padir
persönlich als brutal reinschauender
Boxer auf der sich vor einem Kampf die
Hände bandagiert
[Musik]
halt die Fresse junge guck auf den Boden
so wie mich machst du lieber einen Bogen
nur das Gangster Gabe auf den Straßen
Berlins führt im Herbst 2012 zu einer
Tragödie die bundesweit für Schlagzeilen
sorgt der 20-Jährige Johnny K wird in
der Nacht zum 14 oktober in der Nähe des
Alexanderplatzes totgeprügelt dafür wird
später der Boxer Onur u wegen Totschlags
verurteilt aus dem Kreis der Totschläger
Gang sollen auch Rocker Anwärter stammen
und kardio-padir bleibt die Leitfigur
der jungen migrantischen Rocker im
Wedding die wiederum von den
alteingesessenen und eher deutschen
Hells Angels in Charlottenburg mit
Skepsis betrachtet werden aber es gibt
auch noch Bandidos und deren Anhänger
einer davon ist daher ist weg er hat dir
schon genervt als er mit Straßengangs in
Reinickendorf oder dem Wedding posierte
offenbar sieht er sich als Rivalen des
großen Rockers
nachdem da hier ist weg dann bei einer
Schlägerei einen herzangel vor der Disco
Traffic mit dem Messer verletzt hat
Kadir den Burschen auf dem Kika das
wissen übrigens auch die Berliner
Ermittler seit Dezember 2013 hören Sie
kadierpadirs Telefon ab
am 5 januar 2014 hören sie mit als es
Neues von TAH hier ösberg gibt jemand
erzählt dem Boss das earsback sich schon
wieder über ihn lustig gemacht hat bei
dir ist stinkig wie nie trotzdem wird
Respekt von der Polizei nicht gewarnt
oder bekommt sowas wie Polizeischutz
laut den späteren Aussagen von Zeugen
ordnet bei dir gegenüber rockerkollegen
an sie sollten bei Earth so wörtlich
Präsenz zeigen hieß das der Mann sollte
eingeschüchtert werden oder war dieses
Präsenz zeigen das verschlüsselte
Kommando für einen Mord nach den
Schüssen im Wettbüro gibt es in der
Berliner Rockerszene eine
Verhaftungswelle obwohl bei dem Überfall
einige der Täter Kapuzen auf hatten
werden viele identifiziert als
Haupttäter als Schütze gilt schon bald
der 25-Jährige nachwuchsrocker rece
unter den erstmal elf ermittelten
Verdächtigen ist auch Casa Saga
Perser und als mutmaßlicher Auftraggeber
wird kaliopadir ebenfalls verhaftet ab
November 2014 bemüht sich das
Landgericht Berlin das Geschehen im
Wettbüro aufzuklären und die Täter
abzurteilen getagt wird im mit
Panzerglas gesicherten
hochsicherheitssaal der Kammer fünf
Jahre lang gehen Angeklagte Richter
Staatsanwälte Journalisten und Zuschauer
hier ein und aus aber wird in dem
Verfahren überhaupt jemand Aussagen
in der Rockerszene gilt eigentlich das
Gesetz des Schweigens man kennt das aus
Mafia Film da heißt dieses Gesetz um
merter und tatsächlich will sich ganz am
Anfang nicht mal die Familie ist weg
äußern also die Angehörigen des Opfers
aber wieso oft setzt sich bei den Tätern
ein naheliegendes Interesse durch
den eigenen Hals zu retten
nehmen wir zum Beispiel den Schützen
recepo er kann die Tat schlecht
abstreiten aber er versucht es mit einer
Geschichte in der er auch eine Art Opfer
ist die Geschichte geht so richard ist
angeblich zufällig in der Nähe da drückt
ihm einen imponierender rockerkollege
eine Waffe in die Hand und fordert ihn
auf mit ins Bett Büro zu kommen daher
ist weg solle eingeschüchtert werden
drin habe Respekt dann eine komische
Bewegung gemacht und er Recep habe vor
Schreck geschossen es tue ihm jetzt
schrecklich leid und lieber wäre er
selbst erschossen worden eine wirklich
rührende Geschichte aber womit die
Rocker nicht rechnen einer ihrer ganz
großen Hoffnungsträger wechselt die
Seiten und wird zum Kronzeugen
alias der Perser damals Anfang 30 der
muskulöse Typ mit den Tattoos hat
persische Wurzeln aufgewachsen ist zagan
in Norderstedt bei Hamburg sein Vater
ist Optiker seine Mutter Erzieherin Casa
ist ein Problemkind schmeißt die Schule
vorzeitig und fühlt sich im Hamburger
Rotlichtmilieu wohl er geht Gewichte
stemmen und wird Türsteher von Bordell
über die dortigen Kontakte gerät er an
die Hells Angels nach ein paar Jahren
hat er aber die Zuhälter unter den
Hamburger Rockern satt
er zieht nach Berlin zum Charter von
kardiapadir den findet er cool
zum Zeitpunkt des Mordes im Wettbüro hat
er nach eigenen Angaben längst Zweifel
an seinem neuen Boss padir sei
eigentlich nichts als ein Großmaul ein
Typ der andere gut manipulieren kann und
nur an den eigenen Vorteil denkt jetzt
wo der Prozess begonnen hat will der
Perser Auspacken ja und eigentlich gilt
auch bei den Angels das gangstermoto
ACAB also all Cops a Bastards brauche
ich glaube ich nicht übersetzen aber
zagaran erzählt den Polizisten jetzt
einfach alles wie die Rocker organisiert
sind was sie machen und vor allem immer
wieder Namen wer dabei ist wer welche
Aufgaben hat und schließlich wie Kardio
bei dir den Überfall auf das Wettbüro
anordnete und wer dabei war
im Oktober 2019 geht endlich ein
fünfjähriger Mammutprozess zu Ende daran
beteiligt 346 Zeugen elf Angeklagte 24
Verteidiger fünf Staatsanwälte vier
nebenklageanwälte 8 Psycho Gutachter
zwei Dutzend Justizwachtmeister drei
Richter zwei Ersatzrichter zwei schürfen
drei ersatzschaffen die Urteile
lebenslange Freiheitsstrafen für sieben
Angeklagte wegen gemeinschaftlichen Mord
ist der rocker-chef der die tödlichen
Schüsse in Auftrag gegeben haben soll
wird wegen Anstiftung zum Mord
verurteilt
grundsäuge sage an wird ebenfalls wegen
Mordes verurteilt kommt aber mit 12
Jahren glimpflicher davon auch der 10
Angeklagte erhält eine niedrigere Strafe
weitere Verdächtige haben sich in die
Türkei abgesetzt
Kronzeuge Kasseler sagaran nutzt seine
Haftzeit um ein Buch zu schreiben das
heißt der Perser wie ich ein Hells Angel
wurde als Kronzeuge vor Gericht
auspackte und im Zeugenschutz landete
auf rund 270 Seiten erzählt der von
seiner Jugend in Norderstedt den Weg ins
Milieu und dem Mord er distanziert sich
von den Rockern nennt sie maximal
menschenverachtend zagaran kommt schon
2020 wieder frei seitdem lebt er mit
Frau und Tochter im Zeugenschutzprogramm
ja aber ängstlich ist der Mann nicht um
Werbung für sein Buch zu machen suchte
er den großen Auftritt zum Beispiel in
der bildsendung viertel nach acht wo in
Moderatorin Nena Brockhaus fragt wie er
denn die Haft erlebt hat war sehr hart
muss ich sagen es ist eine sehr maximale
mentale Belastung ich glaube das würde
auch nicht jeder durchstehen ich wusste
es auch nicht das weiß man erst im
Nachhinein ja war aber der Situation
geschuldet der Sicherheitslage damals
einfach rum glaube ich
Avengers Mitglieder dann auch acht
lebenslänglich gemacht haben genau
weitere sind auf der Flucht ich denke
dass da ja und ja es ist halt schwierig
gewesen trotzdem war ich in der Lage
mich so selbst so ein bisschen auch
aufzufangen ich habe sehr viel gelesen
habe mich mit der Prozess war auch sehr
lange fünf Jahre ging ja wo ist erst 21
19 zu Ende gegangen von 2014 bis 219 von
daher war ich da auch sehr viel im Thema
hat mich sehr mit den Akten beschäftigt
war ja auch ein sehr dynamischer Prozess
muss man dazu sagen ja und so habe ich
die Zeit darum bekommen ja viel auch
gelesen sich mit mir selbst
auseinandergesetzt es gab dort einen
Sozialarbeiter der mir sehr geholfen hat
damals und das war sehr sehr wichtig
deswegen meinte ich auch es ist wichtig
dass man jemand hat der einen auch so
ein bisschen raus wird aus dieser
schweren und dunklen Zeit muss man
sozusagen das ist keine schöne Zeit egal
wie man sich das schöne redet und ja das
war halt nicht sehr einfach aber es war
machbar und schaffbar deswegen finde ich
auch harte Strafe sind wichtig wirklich
sie sind wirklich sehr sehr wichtig aber
parallel laufen immer Alternativen und
auch Möglichkeiten geben sie wieder dort
rauszuholen wenn Sie Ihre abgesessen
haben und Kardio padir
bildberichtet im November 2022 Zitat
Hells Angels Boss gibt Befehle aus dem
Knast das geheime Netzwerk der
gefährlichen Rocker demnach regiert der
Mörder per WhatsApp aus seiner Zelle
sein Hells Angels Charger Berlin City
wurde ja längst verboten aber unter
neuen Namen kehren die Rocker immer
wieder zurück mal als Berlin central mal
als Einzelgruppen namens North town East
town soft town westtown auch die
Konkurrenz schläft nicht erst immer
April gab es seit langem mal wieder eine
Schlagzeile über die Bandidos die
feierten in Berlin Tegel eine fette
Party die rockergeschichten in Berlin
sind also wohl noch nicht zu Ende
erzählt aber für heute ist Schluss bei
Tatort Deutschland wir hoffen ihr seid
beim nächsten Mal auch wieder mit dabei
euer Wirkung und eure Toni